as we approach the 20th anniversary of 9
11 the man who says that he organized
the attacks just made his first public
appearance in many months khalid sheikh
mohammed and four co-defendants accused
of helping the hijackers attended a
military court hearing in guantanamo bay
cuba catherine herridge was there
catherine good morning to you
gail i was sitting here in the gallery
of the high security court where
reinforced glass separates us from the
five defendants i was about 15 yards
from khalid sheikh muhammad the
self-described architect of the attacks
he looked much older thinner his beard
long and gray tinted and orangey red on
the sides as the lead defendant he sits
closest to the military judge i was
already out of the courtroom but at one
point he waved to at least one
journalist the others also accused of
war crimes took their seats behind him
as they got settled it had the
atmosphere of a long-awaited reunion
with some smiling talking and gesturing
to each other they have not been
together inside the court for more than
a year and a half
these hearings come as authorities in
new york city identified the remains of
two more victims of 9 11 they're the
first to be identified since october
2019 remains of more than a thousand
victims are still to be identified nate
catherine thank you so much